To create this scatter plot, we're going to use our ggplot function.
And we're going to pass it the Mitchell data frame. We'll pass our
month variable to x and our temperature variable to y and we'll
wrap that in the AES wrapper. And the last thing I'll do is
add geom_point so that way we create a scatter plot. And
there it is. If you use a q plot syntax, it would have
been a little bit shorter. And we still get the same plot.
Again, q plot is pretty smart here since it automatically knows that x
is the month variable and y is the temperature
variable. These variables are passed in alphabetically to the parameters
X, and then Y. Because both X and Y
are used, plot is to make a scatter plot.